are we live did we do it
i think we may have done it hello
friends i'm alana
welcome to this great stream uh i'm
playing grounded today
with um bruce and
uh and john and jacob
uh this is obviously one of the games
that was shown off in the xbox showcase
um made by obsidian who i love looks
cool survival game
they are all generally sort of the same
so we'll see if this does anything
unique other than the cool setting which
is that you play as tiny people
fighting lodge bugs uh i'm excited to
check it out
okay
steve's screen the sea of thieves screen
almost he says
sorry jacob okay yeah i'm in the game
what do i have to do
okay so like join the ship click
multiplayer
yes and then click
join online game okay this all seems
normal says error searching for games
there we go that's right that's you i
see you i'm going to join your game so
you need to join me
join me wow smooth as butter sweet
apparently there's only one way to do it
and it's like this so
that seems fine
that if that's the case it seems okay
i know except totally i we've had we had
lots of problems earlier so
oh well we don't know so that's
excellent
well you haven't joined my game yet
let's see
are pete's or hoops socks higher
i'm sorry what uh you'll see yeah
oh pete's got scoliosis so i was like
sorry okay
okay pete's got the higher damn it
oh man he's got the highest in town bud
yeah
he's gonna lose his glasses in the
second act
we loaded oh oh it didn't work i wonder
why
oh no all right yeah all right all right
i'll try again try it again
just you know there is friendly fire
really nobody attacked me
ah there we are it kicked me okay
what cost all right so just rejoin
am i gonna go a willow or a hoops
i'm hoops yeah i feel like i dress like
willows so let's do a willow
you sure you're not a pete alana i've
got sure i gotta be a willow i mean i
might be a bit of a pete i would swap
with you if you want
i can i get vibes oh okay i'm too
attached now never mind then
i am only hoops
the only character i'd identify with all
right
what now you guys ready yeah i think so
yeah okay let's do it
oh god i hear this
this is fun innocent game with no scares
at all or anything
i am a little bit concerned um but we'll
see how it goes
if i turn my lights off yeah it's too
dark there we go
okay oh my game crashed did it
crash oh no oh no yeah oh no you should
you should be able to rejoin right away
oh so did john's
oh so did alana's uh yeah it's early
access right yes we're trying again
it sure is is it i don't just is it true
i think try and re try and rejoin it it
is early access like is it the part of
the screen that says the title
is pre-release software it is a hundred
percent yeah
all right we'll try again oh it's 0.1
why are you not
hold on
nobody take pete i'm proud of pete now
i'm hoops yeah i think we're both
attachments this doesn't work we'll just
uh like one of you guys can start the
game i'll just join that
okay multiplayer join
look it joining game
oh my god twitch app is freaking out
the music is super cool though it every
time you
tab out it goes away which is very
disappointing
very cool all right loading
joining game oh my god i saw a brief
moment of video game i saw like some
dirt and soil and stuff
was it lit it was
as the kids say lip i don't know what
that means entirely
but i hope it was lit
just let me know if i i do i i googled
uh i googled poggers today
oh yeah oh yeah you did something good
what does that mean i know because i
heard it a lot
in my stream on sundays i was like i
gotta look this up finally after what
does it mean
what it means for for six years it just
means something like
something good happened pretty much yeah
that's all oh that's great
okay cool i just assume that everyone is
presenting negan
right yeah i'm on a joining screen too
you know it's
it said that for like so much so am i
yeah i'm gonna be right back let's do
this
let's go i will also quit out of the
video game
uh-huh so that we can
start fresh um this is what i was
talking about by the way the problems
yes okay all right this is a lot of
joining games
yeah we'll be joining them i i quit out
and i'm uh i'm gonna relaunch my game oh
oh you quit out
okay oh yeah i should do that also oh
because it's uh
it's it has it has its issues it's true
let's try it again
yeah again i mean waldo in chat waldo in
my chat said that he heard this game is
full of bugs so
nice once you get in
it's really not that full of bugs but
but this is where all the bugs are right
now
i heard you're interesting that the game
is called mate i don't get what i don't
get it
no game bugs
errors yeah there we go
try again we'll try again okay i am on
this
start screen
um
her screen is the widest yeah that'll
help
doing this when we scratch from it
validates
our friendship bruce i uh way
i sent you squad stream invites there
they are got
it okay okay invite
hello you're hosting yep
i'm in here hopefully there you are all
right on video game oops
give me hoops activate pete mode
i love that when you activate peat mode
he just kind of goes oh
what a beautiful boy all right stock
game let's let's do it
fingers crossed it's gonna work this
time i'm feeling it i'm feeling it
i'm not touching anything i'm not
touching anything
nope it's like yeah it's like gta you
just got to kind of let it do its thing
yeah you gotta pray a little bit okay i
see the dirt i see the ground
nightmare i'm in the game oh come on
come on video i'm in the game i'm in the
game
oh my god how do i mute you guys escape
and go to playlist
[Music]
well yeah i got some out here by myself
other than before
let's see if i can just join i got
kicked
i'm just going to join you along and see
what happens okay i'm going to just stay
in this nice cave and hope that i don't
die
while you guys try to join me all right
very pretty
quite
[Music]
is that like a smaller pebble i guess
we gotta be pretty tiny for these kids
i will be surprised if this works very
much so
um yeah yeah i was playing with people
earlier though
and everybody could join me but i'd but
if if it doesn't join right away then it
kind of won't great okay so if it's
joining game for a while then it's
probably not gonna happen
oh that was actually pretty impressive
physics
uh oh hello oh no this fails
something exploded and i just genuinely
had the jump scare
i didn't expect any of that to happen
and it did
all right i'm gonna quit again joining
game
he was joining game for quite a while um
moonlight play i don't know i have no
yeah like okay
giant spiders the little launch thing is
actually really cool
oh no oh no yeah i'm too scared to go
anywhere
by myself you guys um this is very
pretty
though it really is we're gonna find a
giant oreo
no spoilers no you don't
the answer is no there is definitely
uniform please don't attack me
you're gonna find you're gonna find
giant spiders everywhere
i want to slide down a big am i already
should i be scared that this is it's
a swimming pool and a bottle cap the
shadow effect is definitely
not looking great out here but
everything else looks really pretty so
just you know just waiting for you guys
all right let me turn off that motion
blur please come back i'm so scared
up that field of view so i can see the
spiders around every corner
okay
all right um did it not walk jacob
um i'm loading right now okay so
that's different than joining game right
okay i mean you can
wait it out if you want leave it out
i'll wait a little bit yeah okay
how much longer should we try we could
try joining on me if this one doesn't
work i mean i've been live for
10 minutes so i like i feel like we
haven't tried for that long
exactly we could keep trying bruce keeps
trying
bruce keeps trying to leave us what man
what are you talking about i was the one
who texted you about this
the texture on the bowl you know love a
good bowl texture
ooh a bowl i'm saying bowl like ball
oh
okay all right i'm tracking a signal um
i'm still waiting for you
you know all right loading loading
loading please
here we go here's where you stand out
what do we do to fix this chat how do we
fix this
how do we feel your time has come chat
time to save the day
let's tweet at the developers
[Laughter]
wait what do you mean when lawrence
couldn't connect he updated basically
all of his systems
there is one thing that i might i might
suggest if this doesn't work but
this is so cute
[Music]
mooji says there's an update via the
xbox app microsoft store
service update oh no oh i just went back
to the main menu great
i got excited for a second all right
someone else want to try host see if we
can
get
[Music]
can i still play with y'all there's a
cross play between pc
and which is this has the option quit
and super quit
which one oh super quick takes you all
the way back to the desktop
alan are you playing on steam or are you
playing on
no i'm on uh xbox game pass
for pc i wonder
uh
downloading the how did you download did
you just pay for it over there too
someone in my chat did you say the pc
version is buggies in the xbox version
at the moment which is interesting
um i am i've got a lobby open though
okay let's give it another shot man
you got game pass bruh
i don't think i do actually
sounds like you're not a real gamer yeah
i did i don't know what happened i think
it expired i didn't know that spectrum
your gamer
expired hello friend i'm here oh god
you have two voices i have to fix have
any of y'all played carrion
yes i played something it was i need to
play more haven't played it yet oh my
god it's so
fun yeah it looks tough it's pretty
short but
it's totally just the right minute game
yeah it seems like
it's totally how long is it like a
couple hours
uh my first playthrough is probably like
four or five hours
my first playthrough i'm in my only
playthrough maybe six all right
bruce is in under 50
um i'm downloading the game
um kryptofc i think we're all playing on
xbox not on steam none of us are on
steam right are you on steam bruce
bruce is on steam maybe i am as well
it's oh
it seems like you guys need to be
playing through xbox
we're about to find out alan i'm at 62
but then why would it even let you join
our online game
like cross play
no no but if it's not cross play with
steam then why is
jacob even showing up and people are
saying it's cross play
i thought you were saying that oh gosh
there was an update on the xbox version
yeah my yeah my chats as they were
playing with a mix of game pass and
steam earlier just fine
okay
they're there i mean where are there
nvidia drivers
i do not have an nvidia just waiting for
a hoops and we'll be good to go
drivers nope can't play a video game
without their hoops amd
i actually want pete's shirt can we talk
about how sick that [ __ ] planet shirt
is
i was thinking about those shorts more
than anything i think i have both shorts
and shoes like that i gotta get me that
shirt
and those socks let's do a peacock my
hair
my hair could never do that though
yeah well yeah no you probably we could
we could straighten your hair just to
see what happens
i mean i've done that before it just
turns into like a frizzy nightmare
yeah i gotta go to a pro though um
that's true from probably i just only
had
like a high school friend to do it and i
think they were just doing it for laughs
uh for everyone who's just 26 game ain't
working
trying to get this game to work we do we
try on our best out here
but right now it is not current everyone
is just joining
take a chill pill wait did you hear me
say that
that whole thing yeah oh you shouldn't
no i was pressing
my discord button oh yeah
we heard it oh let me if i press oh it's
not working
my button that will not work so now you
hear everything i say they are now now
you guys will hear it when i
talk [ __ ] about you to my chat
i mean how's that different from our
normal conversations
uh what is it push to mute and we like
to put that on a nice f9
how about now how about now this is one
to really be grounded
laugh laugh jacob both vic and i are on
steam version still right
yeah yes which supposedly is working for
people
so you know john you don't need to
download the xbox version
of it i already did well
all right hoops waiting on hoops i'm in
the xbox version come on hoops
here i come i refuse to play video game
unless there's a hoops
on my in my school he's on the spot
joining
so bruce you played this alley yeah
what'd you think i did
hours of it i really liked it a lot yeah
okay i didn't i wasn't able to mute
y'all that's okay
you gotta do it yeah i really i really
liked it a lot it was the
it was it'll feel small once we get to
the end of it
i mean well we didn't finish it we
finished like the story part of it
basically
um all right i'm in let's run through
and
keep running boys never stop but where
is it player list start picking up stuff
pick up rocks
conveniently i don't think my game audio
is picking you guys up
yeah you have to mute us i don't think
it's picking you up but the stream can
tell me if it is i don't think it is
though for some reason i've got a
pebblet
plant fiber ah beautiful oh
what's the crafting button oh here we go
i'm somehow still hearing
spring plant flavor oh wow wow
well but do you hear them twice it's my
question
thank you you're not hearing it
oops is belligerent i'm getting yeah i'm
getting double from
a lot of people so here let's do this i
have tracked the signal too it's soft
yeah can you hear me um hit escape hit
escape and go to options
apply okay and go to
audio audio voice chat
activation i'm just going to turn it off
right yes how's that mate
ah there it is fixed beautiful
car i can make a roasting spit now
that's uh that's a hell of a start
all right okay i've made a pebble spear
or a
a sprig spear or something where are my
pablets at
whoa okay so here's the deal
um pick up lots and lots of stuff
just get stuff
the ants seem nice though i think maybe
like a little
little rocks degrees all right i love a
gathering simulator
wait wait for pete pete fell behind what
else is new
cruz can you hear me i can hear you but
i have
double audio oh no i turned off my voice
chat
oh my gosh oh so cute no no
i have double audio in there are these
ants friendly game audio
double game audio right now oh that's
not [ __ ]
that's all there's some kind of little
fly plant fiber plant fiber
i don't feel like i've played many
survival games that start out with like
characters with vo you know like
this is this i'm used to just being
dropped in a world with nothing
um and no characters seems kind of
interesting
hey uh how do you guys feel about ants
should we kill ants
i would prefer not to but we need their
goop
we may need that goop yeah he makes it
loves killing
oh hell yeah leaf thank you
i need woven fibers where do you find
those woven fibers at
uh probably the oh i got plant fibers
look at me
whoa
nice hoops your ass is grass this flies
trying to
claw exploded what do i do with this
i'm i'm really confused right i have i
have double audio from someone
now i got double oh double bruce
wait are you getting i don't i don't i
have no idea how to help
no i i'm getting double audio from like
from someone who's sending their game
audio to me
to you oh no why would they be sending
oh i'm not sure so if you hit escape and
go to player list you can mute that
yeah i muted everybody i did yeah i just
did it
is it over discord or no i think
all right i think it may be fixed
i'm dropping down leaves willy-nilly the
big he's still he's a ladybug
he's so cute hello okay all right so
um yeah pick up rocks pick up plant
fibers the grass
and stuff the big grass that you just
chopped down you'll need for bases
oh but
uh if you if you kill a ladybug i will
absolutely murder you
[Music]
yeah so okay so uh do you have stones do
you have stones
uh yeah dude i got like 15 stones that's
a bug that's another bug
great i love to see that here's the
here's what you do
the water is above you and there are
droplets
so find a water droplet and then throw a
rock at it and it'll fall
oh cute yeah
okay some water maybe on a leaf
somewhere you say basically
yeah it'll be the dew will be kind of
like hanging out on the blade of grass
basically okay
oh john look out picking up what you're
putting down
you just got to find it sometimes it can
be hard to find okay
where'd my weevil go i'm killed an amp
what the hell john okay i got ant
arm how do you know how do you know that
i killed an ant
i have found the ice caps mint container
yeah i thought
yeah i'm looking for water yeah yeah i'm
also looking for water do you want to
group together while we look
you're back here john the ants are all
over you
john's just killing him he's killing it
well i found water on the ground i need
armor bruce are we aggravating the
creatures
by attacking them nah it's fine you can
it's you can do whatever you want
okay so you said the water is in dew
drops so alana you can drink this water
but it'll be oh [ __ ]
oh okay i prefer to avoid this oh i
found one [ __ ] answer
ah that's true i need help
also did i miss it jacob hold on hold on
i think because i wasn't standing
directly underneath the water i may be
[ __ ] up oh no
oh who's going down hoops is dying oh my
god what happened
hoops is covered in ants look my kids
attacked an animal of some sort
oh my god okay
john oops run
well these ants don't seem to care 70
centimeters away
things that's delightful yeah who's i
just picked up a hot dog
okay i got a hot dog bit yeah john
yeah bruce ants are pissed at you
because you hit him
oh and aphid oh did joe did you just say
no i didn't
yeah he totally did they wouldn't be
chasing believers
ants never lie
mushrooms mushrooms you can also eat by
the way
oh i've got some of those water
uh do you see any of the big mushrooms
the little mushrooms would be all around
am i gonna run into a spider like while
i'm walking around looking up should i
be that
concerned um don't be too concerned i
mean you'll
you're gonna get scared by the first
spider you see i promise you that okay
oh cave
pete loves caves oh my gosh
i've never found this okay hold up oh
so i attacked oh my god there's a scary
ant coming out and then i have to like
be perfectly below oh no just
there's a soldier aunt and he's mad
great
there's a spider i see a spider
staggered on me because i
i'll kick their bruce does the soldier
ain't chasing me what do i do
uh just leave just get out of here get
out of there craft i gotta crap bandages
i think i can see your veggies oh my god
okay i now need food is that a spider
how are you guys i'm getting out of here
you can see where we are if you look
oh my god that is a spider how do you
craft bandages oh my gosh
oh boy oh hit tab tab tab
and then go to uh craft and then click
on snacks
for some reason it's in there oh snacks
okay
i don't want any of that i need i need a
sap does there sap in these logs
there are sounds generally okay i'm
gonna hit some
oh [ __ ] oh god oh we just we're in
spiders on
jesus christ there are tons of them did
you find it i did
i did not find the zap the spider is
[Music]
[Applause]
the sound really really got me
oh god i don't know what spiders sound
like
i mean you're probably right oh i hate
it oh i have chills i wanna
i might be able to get you oh he's right
there though dude
oh
i ran the wrong way i ran to more
spiders i left australia for a reason
how do i distract it oh it's like it's
right on me if you die you can you can
run back and get your back back
oh
that's very handy thank you friends oh
my god get me the [ __ ] out of here
yeah seriously oh okay i made a bandage
i'm okay oh god there's so many ants
oh there's three oh god dance there's
the anthill right here look at this
cool oh can we live there joe john
please don't hit the ants because
they'll look like
oh my god can we can we pause the queen
the ants oh i don't trust this john
if you go further down in here then
you're going to find some evil ants i
promise
okay evil ants right now i would just
like to stay away from spiders
uh find food yeah here let's find some
food let's find i need to find some sap
okay sap right here i trust you
let's go here how do i make a graph
flashlight here get some of this sap you
need to
use it to make bandages john you want a
torch
and you need uh gnats you need to kill
some nats
and slime torch like plant fibers i
don't want a torch i want a flashlight
slime mold 42 wing oscars is the alpha
or beta version of the game i don't know
it just said it's pre-released
i would guess it's alpha but i don't
know also
also if you if you got oh she's the
stink [ __ ] this thing
oh geez what's up what's happening this
thing [ __ ] over here
you guys do you guys see what's wrong
with stink bugs
check me out they blast you with uh like
stinky [ __ ]
nice that's my king nobody nobody
everything kills me
bruce look at me oh jesus christ
oh hey what's up pete has invented fire
also if you guys want third person hit z
oh hit z and then uh
the very top center one click that
cool huh
i think i prefer pete doesn't like
seeing himself in any capacity
i i like what about that [ __ ] shot
though dude cool
um okay i need to find food and also
there you go there we go um
can i craft
oh no the mushroom is worse than pete's
dad's brussels sprouts
snacks i had a mushroom you didn't heal
me at all fiber bandage i think you need
uh bandages for
that i need more sound oh there's a food
and
a water meter guys you want to see a
giant fight i want to see a fight
as long as i will be safe from the fight
battle come over here come over here
check it out
are you serious i mean ants i think the
ants are going to fight too
no no no
all right they kill that spider
i'm with you i'm with you i'm with you
let's go
are the stink bugs mean even being
around a dead spider
oh pick up the [ __ ] pick it up
what [ __ ] oh poopy i think he just means
the literally
tagging facebooks are tagging i think i
got it
they're raising a stink
[Music]
that's gonna help us i am very stressed
out by the scale of this game
um so that's certainly a thing okay
where do i find that's what i said about
assassin's creed odyssey
that's fair that's awesome john you
remember those little
little fuzzy guys that were attacking us
at the very early little
yeah little flies those were gnats
they looked like that all right i need
to find saps yeah
yeah find sticks little sticks and twigs
of sap on them
investigating any more plants
well these stink bugs are really
stinking [ __ ] up
cool these are my favorite bugs as a kid
oh no no that's not what i think it is
really running out of food um
what's this dry grass chunk no i need
plant fibers growling
i heard growling oh no it's pizza oh no
i'm
ladybug bruce oh that's all right uh
just
just uh what the [ __ ] is that circle of
life
yeah no no just just pick up his [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah ant mandibles no
i'm not picking i protect the ladybug oh
that's nice to you
music started uh i feel like maybe i'm
being chased based on the music
i am there is an aunt chasing me
it's chasing me i'm sorry i let it right
to you oh
what i'm sorry i'm really right in your
pocket
okay i'm gonna beat you up you stupid
[ __ ] oh i'm so low on health i can't
i can't i'm gonna do it with this rock
oh little ass
oh i'm sorry i don't want anything i
don't i don't have any beef with you
so stop it an aunt bit my bottom
okay oh that's so weird oh
i'm down
yeah why isn't the ladybug helping us
breathe man
these ants knew how many of anz of their
brother and i vacuumed up um
okay i really didn't i can't i don't
have enough help for any of this
i just need to find more beat jacob no
i'm gonna ride this late i'm gonna ride
this ladybug this ladybug is
demolishing ants over here please don't
attack so helpless
thank you bruce are both down oh [ __ ]
okay uh stuck on plants max i'm trying
to come back
this is the jock is the killer that i
may also
die if i don't think i can do it i don't
think i can do it i'm [ __ ] running
does anyone have sex with their ladybug
also bruce can you share
things from inventories yeah yeah yeah
so um
if you drop you can just uh like right
click and do drop
okay jacob i think that i have something
that you want and you have something
that i want
yeah what do you need um i need sap what
are you looking for
um i don't think i'm looking for
anything but i do have some sap
hold on i could i could just use a nice
sap you know just a cute little snap
how do you drop things again drag them
uh hit tab
you can drag it but i think you hit tab
right click on it and do drop
requires workbench right click doesn't
materials
maybe i don't have any oh no i think i
used all of it
that's fair okay we can go on a sap hunt
though yeah
because i'm trying to make a five
bandage but i need i need
for a bandage because i weak as [ __ ]
yeah look for like
twigs and stuff because there's always
sap on the side of them but it looks
like
i'm hey jacob will you do me a favor you
come over here and just hit me
just knock me down yeah there you are i
think my uh
is that what you say to autumn what just
just just hit me
hit me just come over here and just hit
me i'm doing it
yeah okay now now revive me
okay sorry max because my screen is all
bugged right now
good nice
spider you wanna kind of just like
quitting and joining again or something
yeah i may do that what happened oh
i think the sun's setting guys i don't
like that it just shows my screen is
poisoned all the time
oh um all right
i need to find more snaps too i know i'm
not seeing any
there's a giant machine here yes
just so you know there's a spider right
on the other side it's not a snail
oh okay press the button on the top of
that
on the top of that uh wow what is this
contraption
oh i could just go let's investigate
john let's do that oh no
it's spider territory i'm not going
anywhere to get any of this
oh god oh oh
no no that sounds about right
damn are we gonna lose all that
jacob you might be able to re-host okay
should i just like sit here and try
you guys can rejoin me oh yeah yeah oh
you're still in it
all right i'm still in wait oh it just
kicked us
here i go yeah hurry guys the sun is
setting and i'm getting scared oh boy
pete's gonna wet his little jimmies
okay i guess
i need some water
wow something magical the way the light
shines through the grass that's nice
can't relate just black just just black
screen
if it doesn't work quitting
well it seems like if you drop out of a
game
you can't rejoin
[Music]
yeah but it's it lies okay no i mean
jacob you still you stay in
because you didn't crash but i'm
quitting my game okay
and then starting it over okay all the
way up i'm trying to i'm trying to
rejoin it but it's not working
okay yeah that's what i was saying is
that it seems like
if you drop out of a game yeah then you
can't
try to join a game again until you
relaunch the app
yeah i have relaunched i will attempt
again
okay i'll just keep wandering around in
the woods
stay safe i mean the backyard
why didn't my channel close uh you say
you got here just in time for crashing
blew the game cat that that was not
awful from
match fuzz and woven fiber i know that's
why i'm trying to find gnats
we sound like a bunch of dudes i ignored
them
i did too like a fool
pete you fool
ooh i can
sent me a text that says [ __ ] paper
mario
[Laughter]
he sent me a similar message like a week
ago so i guess he's still playing it
all right let me know how would uh how
it's going
i am uh i don't know i don't know that
this is gonna
you're right what what you didn't finish
your sentence
this game may be like jacob may have to
restart it you know
yeah apparently it has a really good
auto save so
that's what i'm reading right now so it
shouldn't i guess thank you
that it had bugs okay you want me i
could just like
quit yeah all right i'm quitting i'm not
super quitting but i'm quitting
okay multiplayer post online game
continue at least when it crashes it's
late
creating lobby
xbox on yeah it sounds like people just
say rejoining is the
the thing to do so i guess that's what
we doing
all right i have created a lobby try it
again
we still got to listen to this sweet
tune the music's cool
yeah yeah now as cool as max's torn
jeans though
no thanks is cool nothing's as cool as
max we all know that
max where's the tank top
his shirt says whoa on it
that's what's up
uh yeah malcolm this is on
pc it's on steam it's on xbox um
so yeah not an xbox this is a fully
released polished game
sorry
all right uh jacob are you going to
re-host yeah i've got a lot
lobster on twitch being cool on switch
that i will join you
there my name is
oh god okay mute
it sounded scary what happened
for some reason the voice is all
distorted
it sounds like a demon it's better than
you could say this game has bugs
all right lyrics thank you yeah
it's not on the box dang it
uh yeah jack i got this free with game
pause i ate some of those little
mushrooms and
peeps set in separate occasions as them
being as bad as
dads and also mom's brussels sprouts
hell yeah oh i see my friends
okay let's go see you okay that's a
[ __ ] spider right there
get me out of this of this oh boy turn
motion blur back on
okay jesus christ oh i've never found
this before
what is this all right what's that from
spider i need a sap
oh i have a snail shell okay guys
um spider got me i was in my mind oh my
god already
also what wow that was something i just
popped up on my mind
what what the [ __ ] am i looking at
oh you're building i think so
oh oh my god oh jacob spider
what what it's right behind where where
literally
right there oh my god
jacob uh you need john are you okay i
don't know where it's safe anymore
i rest myself okay i made a lean too
i'm holding a few right now uh i'm about
to starve to death how to make food
an aphid food you gotta probably find
um okay maybe i have some in my
inventory do i have anything edible
can i eat this ant pot it's hot dog pot
can i eat that
okay so i placed down like a thing like
a little outline of a lean too how do i
build it
uh you click great yeah and then
um like head left right maybe right
click or deselect or whatever oh
here we go
it's that respawn point i'm just doing
the machine thing
okay what happens if you
sleep does it just go to the morning
unlock the obstructed laser apparently
yeah so if we all go to if we all go to
sleep then uh
then it will basically you guys like my
lean too and take a nap
okay yeah i guess we i feel like we
should
don't think we can yet i think you can
only do it um you can only do it when
it's nighttime
oh yeah we still got two hours till
night time uh let me see if i can crop
here guys uh come to me we'll do this
we'll do this thing together it's fun
i'm
kept killing them all no it's because i
died and they're going through my
backpack
well that makes sense
trying to steal from you i didn't do
anything to him
except for murder a bunch of them all
right lads
what it up yeah
i am and uh i'm trying
oh geez what's this oh what did you oh
geez
uh just little lawn mites there you'll
see okay ew gross
take their business you makes me ticks
uh
okay is everybody here no they're eating
the wires wow they really are
is everybody i am here yeah yeah we're
all here
oh god i should craft a tool probably
let's do that i do not have any woven
they're eating the wires yeah yeah knock
them off the wire and also knock them
off the wire
no weapon got it okay missed okay
kill them all off the wire here
i got myself a spear and then
come on and down in here whoever's got
the torch goes first
oh okay oh god no
pete doesn't like that first one
stab him max has one health
yeah trust me i know
i need abandon but i need clovers i was
stabbed oh gosh
did i i might have stabbed you
[Music]
okay um and then uh yeah let's just keep
keep stabbing these bad boys
sons of [ __ ] now i'm scared of
hitting any of you though
that's all right it's there's no penalty
i'm down i'm down
i don't know what happened but i'm down
okay
all right thank you uh yeah make sure
you pick up your slime
didn't realize that oh wait we need
let's pick up what
sports site to get through here uh you
need a hammer so has anybody made a
hammer
uh yeah let me see what i can make a
pebblet hammer
i need two rocks oh my god i can make a
hammer
uh it won't let me pick up the slime
mold i made a hammer and it disappeared
yeah come pick it up i gotta go find a
couple rocks before i can
bust through there what no can't take
any of that
it's eating my [ __ ] oh there it is all
right whoever's got the hammer i hammer
on the
accidentally made two hammers there you
go can you drop can you drop one of them
for us
yeah i think uh
let's figure this out you just right
click on it and then it'll just go drop
i think the character animations are
really cute come on
oh gosh oh pd oh this is a spooky skull
or a spooky torch it makes things green
oh neat that's okay it makes me feel
more immersed
oh yeah i dropped it that's cool oh yeah
there it is somebody pick it up
where did it okay i got it uh
pete's arms are too weak to swing
hammers
yeah it's okay we understand you serve
your pup as well which is like
smashing e whoever's got uh the hammers
there's another there's some quartzite
back here too
right over here
okay ma'am yeah nail in there
got some slime mold over here come on
knock out all this courtside if you can
because we'll probably need it later
there's there's port side at the very
bottom okay i think i took it all and
now i can't see [ __ ]
okay all right all right
what is that what what's up the ground
is moving
what what there's nothing wrong with
that yeah
are you guys really not seeing that
right there at the ground yes
right thank you
look at this right there yeah that's a
grub so if we had a shovel
uh we could dig that up and use it to
get a canteen
ah store some of that water we're good
to go so you guys can
we can leave so come pick those wait
there's some there's a quartzite over
here
okay i don't have a disc knock it out i
need to go get some water and stuff
yeah i could really use my food
i don't know i just picked it up cool
let's roll it was just sitting there on
the floor
it's dark as hell you probably go back
and nap
we should oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my
gosh jacob you're my source of light and
you're leaving oh my god jacob
pete's so scared i got real panicked out
of the way
thank you okay i need more woven fight
yes woven fibers yeah i will make that
from
playing flies let's make yeah get pop
fiber and then go in there got it
got it yes right that sounds wonderful
bloody
when you say it that way i have so much
confidence john
bugs aren't attracted to light are they
yeah yeah
oh cutscene cutscene all right so i did
the thing for us
oh we get to jump on buttons like little
tiny people cool
oh rick moranis is at it again
whoa what do you mean you did a thing
this is the thing that you
throw it out yeah what
so it starts that fire over there we got
to go over there basically you broke it
okay public event uh what if we napped
first
yeah let's let's go now where is the
thing does anybody know where the link
is
it was uh near here i don't remember
everything
materials yeah we'll probably have to
make another one
okay let's see i can make an axe so
utilities lean to i need three clover
leafs
oh here's some over here oh hit me with
that already
all right no here you go crimson and
clover
and over and over
all right crafting cool hat
right down here okay yeah put it down
and then
remove those lights sleep everybody
sleep
the way you said that john you said i
was trying to chase some lights i
thought
oh wait so we just how to sleep
go up to the lean too oh that's it oh
and then oh
we all just sleeping we're all just
sleeping in this tiny little
leaf pile up this guy is not realistic
so
who's gonna tuck in pete oh it
oh my raw nat meat spoiled no no oh no
oh yeah that happens okay wait do you
have nat
fuzz so uh jacob
yes yes since generally jacob's four of
them
jacob is our man who normally builds
bases
yeah you bet that's true he is so jacob
if you find a good spot you're going to
need a lot of grass
and we can be like your uh your
scavengers
that that guy okay that sounds perfect
what
what what would bring you a place to
work wherever you want truthfully
wherever you want there's so
if you want elevation follow me yeah
follow me and i'll show you i'll kind of
i think i think this is the right way
oh no my stamina the oak tree okay
all right i'm following water and did i
not make a yeah sam don't make an axe i
need to get some food and water yeah i
also really need food
i should probably just look for dew
drops cause i'm just not rig i need more
spring okay okay there's some
hold on
hold on i just really gotta pick stuff
up huh
at least it's not like seven days to die
where all i was doing was knocking stuff
down
getting some variety in my survival
games these days you guys i'm loving it
yeah it's confusing
[Music]
okay so there's a over here this is fun
over here oh geez
oh it's that thing it's a cool little
cool it's all right because it makes me
really nervous
yeah it's something's moving the grass
over here
oh god it's after you there's a spider
oh god there are two spiders and stink
bugs
oh great
giant rock for us to build on i see that
right i'm standing right next to you
oh there's ants everywhere there's ants
everywhere oh hey what's up
the big
let's go help max good luck
yeah i don't want to fight no spiders
can you fight them you're brave
i need three bricks
oh god a big old weevil or something
that's coming at me
you can somebody can come probably come
get me now
john now's your chance i don't know the
rock uh
i don't know is anybody near me i'm sort
of near you not terribly
but i don't mind coming to get you if
it's
whatever oh yeah oh the weevils after me
oh
lordy still i really am i'm going to
both uh stop and um
oh this isn't a real rock and thus
you forgot the word for no oh no bruce i
just got here
oh that's all right um i'm going to run
over there
okay also
when we put it down and leave it there
you can make it your respawn point and
that's useful as well
yes okay jacob i made you made it up
there
yep yes was it easy yeah
i found a big can a soda can i want to
put it in my inventory did i not make it
oh
yes yes
are you okay yeah i just didn't expect
it
is that weevil going to attack me
and i was just looking at crossing
guarding your body yeah you
trying to fight me even more big [ __ ]
judge
hello i'm gonna go back to my back oh
god oh god oh no
should i jump down i got 10 seconds bro
oh right there oh god
oh god no
oh there's a spider coming as well
oh my god well there we go
where did you choose to build um i'm i'm
near
where that rock that you're talking
about but there's like a way to get on
the rock i was about to show you
i'm gonna come back i'll show you how to
get on top of the rock you need help
bruce
no i jumped in the water [ __ ] pete's
getting hungry
[ __ ] you well i got my water and food
back i would really like my backpack so
i'm gonna
go try and do that yeah that was my
thought too john i was like oh well at
least i'm not
um starving to death anymore john i got
up
i jumped on the phone yeah from the rock
to the bladed grass to the
oh yeah i see if you see me if you're
gonna do if you're gonna do a fight with
the spider and you want to run away go
to the water they can't go in the water
okay there's a whole bunch of spiders
over there i see them
there you go boom okay you think this
will be good
uh yeah it'll be yes yeah yes
it'll be safe oh [ __ ] i'm poisoned
oh jesus okay i need grass i need lots
of grass john did you manage to safely
get your backpack back am i am i gonna
be able to get there i did
i did glasses oh there's a spider right
[ __ ] that uh
so here's what i'm gonna do there wasn't
when i was there
i'm gonna bring you some grass right now
okay okay you can just
you can just bring it up here and just
pile it up oh god okay
the problem with this is that i'm so
scared of spiders and i'm just
perpetually getting chills
okay take all of my stuff please those
spiders are so scary
yeah they're like the scary yeah they're
the gross kind
huh oh you guys did that okay there you
go
all right yeah let's pile it up i'm
gonna go get some as well
um bruce where do you get fighting with
your wood stems
um so food okay so we when we built our
base
we built our base by a tree and there
were a bunch of acorns there and that
was really
really useful a tree you say um
and uh because the acorns are food and
they're just like cons
and they're actually really good food
okay but in terms of other food like
uh sap you can't you can eat
if we make a campfire we can uh we can
kill whatever we eat
yeah cause i'm getting hungry
yeah i drink uh i drink ground water
and it took all my food points away yeah
don't drink ground water yeah
okay it wants us to investigate that
explosion i'm just going to keep picking
up stuff
and hoping i come across food or water
i need oh so i can't carry more grass
planks to craft
oh no wait
no i do have enough but i need a
workbench damn it okay
workbench workbench tools
base building utilities
we are good on water we need food
where is the work bench prepared arrows
though you can make a workbench yeah
okay
uh ant club yeah
i feel like i'm changing my settings and
nothing is happening
like it's still in 1440 and i set it to
low
and everything still looks great see
what happens
let's see where is the work dimension
here
the workpiece is like oh [ __ ] i forgot
am i passing it
do you see that he actually likes a tiny
bit of motion blur
right onto the rock okay jacob um oh
those are glitch now it is
i put the i put the grass inside your
body i know why
what i know we have to go we have to go
to those labs
and research the stuff that we picked up
oh
i researched like a little little uh
little ant head
this area so we need to go and do that a
lot that's another reason that this
bill this base may not be the greatest
because
it's the highest we're not by a lab it
is the highest
so those labs they're like those labs
are stationary
they don't go anywhere else right right
it's okay how many of you already
i can show you oh jesus oh boy
this game's doing this weird thing to me
where whenever anyone else is panicking
i'm genuinely panicked on their behalf
whereas i feel like most survival games
i'm like you'll be fine
and this one i'm like what is it is it
to spider oh no
i gotta find this lab they're like those
little white buildings right
guys if you look up if you wake up yeah
you see the red tree
so you ready to see that yeah walk
toward that
okay okay there's a spider all right
goes to tsushima there's a spider
oh yeah oh god
[Music]
sneaky sneaky i mean should i be
moving i alerted a threat oh god is it
the spider
yeah that's definitely a spider
don't worry about it
i'm fast i'm as fast as an ant
oh there's my lean too i never finished
that's right
oh yeah beautiful
evaded okay oh still i need food
[ __ ] of that [ __ ] yeah sam i need food
too what's this thing i just want
food in here no what is this ice caps
cool breath mints there's some kind of
candy in there yeah it's
breath oh i got soda
it's a juice box tropical punches
tropical
spots there you go it's useful uh
because you can find
stuff to drink there and it like give me
juice a lot of
full water now what the [ __ ] are these
mushrooms i think i found a glitch
there's like oh no tape cassettes and
weapons
and everything floating over here
everything's gasping you don't want to
see it
it sounds like a glitch um i guess
yeah i'll see that i'm gonna come in i
got some raw aphids
there's also some some juice here if you
want to slurp it up
i'm okay on liquid unless that is i see
some mushrooms
uh what am i looking at do you not see
these floating tapes here
nope on the way no
i want to see them that is not a thing
alana does not see them
no i just see this little bulb
um no tapes no tapes i mean unless
you're talking about
the [ __ ] you're holding no i'm coming
over to see here like
cassette tapes that seems odd
the best place so far that i've seen to
build a base is the oak tree but i don't
i could be right let's do it
i want to it looks really cool i want to
go over there
i can make this is there a lab over
there or whatever so that's pretty neat
yeah
let's take some did i poison myself
anybody hungry i see some uh
mushrooms over there nope i'm good i
think that's good i ate them
did that what did that help oh i don't
have to step i have a butt load of
honeydew oh yeah that's uh you can eat
that stuff giving me more oh
detecting base sweet food
nice did you find a base okay um i'm
heading towards one
detecting base it's like a
train tracker oh i think i passed it
oh it's cool over here
what's that oh my god it's me it's me
it's okay it's just me
hello friend i'm also getting the
detecting bass thing got some sap over
here
hmm i think it is a terrible idea that
when you run out of stamina in this game
it plays a heartbeat sound
because heartbeat sound usually means
like again like a threat detected okay
there are acorns here
so this this seems like a good
yummy yeah acorns are great big horns
are great
i need a hammer yeah yeah i still need
to make a hammer
relatively easily didn't i already make
one of those
is my three not a hammer it is okay
cool worry about it figuring the [ __ ]
out sometimes
sometimes you got it you got to put
stuff in your like
quick bar or whatever yeah i think that
i already i think i have two now but one
of them i do yeah
um i'm gonna just leave that acorn there
well oh so much
the lab is around here if you want to
follow me
um yeah we gotta start researching my
doctor
yeah acorn bits you can just eat those
yeah yes oh delicious
i really need oh i found the lab okay
i'm at the lab great let's go i see you
are you underneath a tree yeah
i'm underneath the leaf actually you
should scan whatever you want john scan
scan three things here i go
and then uh i'll show you where the
actual lab is
the actual lab yeah because there's a
there's like an underground lab
there's a space by web right there yeah
i like it my lab's cooler
oh boy i'm analyzing
[ __ ] up no more charge
oh we gotta wait for it to charge that
might be a spider maybe i guess
yeah that's going to be a spider that's
going to be a spider that's going to be
a spider heading towards us
where's the lamb you're talking about
bruce oh you're over there come to where
i come to ryan okay
okay on my way to take that
here comes peter
my name is ali hoops it's a pun
drink the water right out of there
spider i'm really taking a rescue
oh my god did a lot of go through the
tree
[ __ ] we're leaving we're leaving we're
living oh [ __ ] through the tree oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh no are you indeed i'm fine i'm not in
danger i was just close to you
underneath you can go underneath the
tree uh
i don't know that i'd recommend it but
okay hard pass
not doing that no i just was near a
spider
there's lots of little droopy sap things
underneath the roots and stuff too
come to where i am yeah everybody on my
way
i got sap so much zap
what is that oh those are those big
mushrooms over here
i wanna get all these acorns i don't
ever be hungry again
mushrooms do the acorn tops do anything
dana
uh they do yeah yeah clicked everything
collect it all okay
collected everything near you
two spiders right there oh my gosh
john watch out watch out there's two of
them run
yeah what's this thing oh that one looks
like a wolf spider they don't attack a
human uh-huh sure yeah what about tiny
humans bro
my inventory's full that happens a lot
of this okay
we're all right where are right hey
hey that was my acorn water okay
all right come this way follow me
probably all right i'm all about that
cool one
room for this stuff i gotta get the corn
okay i got it okay
oh you're behind me all right oh
you guys brought that spider out didn't
you okay you know that's
that's from the other way bruce oh boy
that's angry spiderwebs in the opposite
direction
all right come to come to where i am
that's us
[Music]
john already ran inside he showed up so
[ __ ] dead
that is a worse spider than the other
spiders that we've been seeing
we're doing it we're doing it i'm here
all right get in there
go explore okay oh my god there was i
saw a spider and it was like a scarier
spider
what in the [ __ ]
oh my gosh
he's a nerd i pulled a lever
cool yeah so there's a puzzle puzzle oh
that's a puzzle
okay turn them all right i'll pull the
lever
i did it it was the simplest puzzle ever
great
data link cool who built this
there's an angry robot there's an angry
robot attacking me coming to assist
oh tease he's attacking me beat the [ __ ]
out of that robot
oh so brittle preet's got weak bones
we [ __ ] showed that [ __ ] stunned him
oh so weak wait i'm not rezzing you
i rezzed burgle yeah wake up burgle
hello science manager for this project
hi i love you you're a nerd
can you hug his mustache oh he's gay
mustache
unfortunately this is all speculation
because a power surge
okay charging batteries
i gotta research some stuff yeah you
goddamn nude ah
that's the end of the story i'm already
doing it
um it basically is the end of the story
content yes wow
for now okay game preview until next
time
bruce used all the charges i did
you're right uh does anybody have any
research cards
uh cause if you have an instagram party
used
throw it in there throw it in that
burger
you're using what those look like uh
that's a good question because i don't
know that i've found one yet
oh that's a loop okay
i like what it's doing with this like
this could potentially be
really interesting and i feel like again
survival games usually don't do that so
no research cards that's cool oh there
we go
grasslands burgle chips somebody found
one uh yeah i just picked like a request
oh yeah throw it in there throw it in
what's his name
throw it in bubble burgle buggle has a
like a no
sign on him that's because somebody's
talking about uh here we go
we found a bubble [ __ ] bro
okay i gave it to him
all right what are these tape cassettes
so here what i'll just do this floor all
right so somebody accepted the quest
spade gulch let's see if i can
complete mockery great oak beacon and
spade gold okay lots of requests popping
up there
yeah we're a little bit short on the uh
science we need a little more science
analyzing acorn top i agree bruce we do
need a little more science
how did you put juice into it this gives
you just came back
now it's empty again
all right this is cool
yeah so that's the that's burgle and i
love
i like this mechanic that's about as far
as i got for the uh for the story quests
i don't know if there's more
i think that's kind of it i mean it
certainly said it was yeah
well let's build a base dog yeah
oops i threw my spear and i think it
fell through the floor no oh no
i got it i don't have questions i gotta
go
chatting up burger i gotta go now um
okay well yeah i have some mop
apparently
my spear go there it is
are we uh going going base making is
that the plan
yeah hell yeah you guys pick a spot
where are you going jacob where are you
going what are you doing
i'll just check everything and you
charged it yeah i can make a workbench
now
oh good sweet yeah pick a spot
it's super interesting i'm into it we
will see it who's making all this
smoochy sounds
okay oh aphid hello
wow okay jacob all right jesus pete has
changed
yeah all this time outside it's hard and
pete yeah
oh is that ladybug fighting someone no
it's okay
um can i break down the mushrooms
uh i don't know that's a good question
all right i need some grass
okay some grass you said
any grass to make that work mitch hi big
cutie what are you
oh spider oh it's fine uh
just five i'll i'll just get some get me
out of this house over here oh my god
um oh the spider has seen me
this threat has been engaged cortana
keep opening
get out of here cortana
i don't know what to do i don't want to
leave the spider to you guys but okay
jump in the water alana jump in the pond
where is water
where is that water please be water this
might be the edge of the map rather than
water oh my stamina oh
no what about under that big
lamp over there underneath the tree yeah
let's do it i think i invaded it but i'm
scared to turn it around
it was kind of close to that base that
to the research thing that john found
okay okay this is the coolest no stop it
please
don't stop approaching me just go in a
different direction
we could build like under these roots
here does this seem oh that's kind of
close to the entrance there
right next to the spider base but this
is fine it's okay it's really all right
let's clear all this out and build this
little spot here all right i'll drop
this and start clearing
i'm gonna drown myself you guys see you
in another life
oh no
okay utilities i no longer have eyes on
spiders
all right i'm building the workbench i
need this leaf great
hell yeah john isn't saying no it's not
safe john john john have you seen it
have you seen it literally like that
[ __ ] outrun the spider don't worry
about it
what up [ __ ]
that was quick
[Laughter]
let's see i need to make acorn pieces or
whatever
elana can you help me uh i can't just
right on top of me
well then probably not no i probably all
can't
um is the spider walking away i can't
see it right now
what do you need no i don't need a what
are they called let me see real quick
okay
uh acorn shell how do you get that i
hear i've got it oh yeah i think i might
even have a few
do not loot mike thank you no i'm
carrying i'm carrying
stuff hold on there you go
let me just build some walls and whatnot
the spider went in this direction but i
don't know
so i don't know if maybe i woke up this
way i will be safe
there's a ladybug i might just be fine
you shouldn't have mine i don't
run it yeah that but i
you know would prefer to not be scared
so there's that um i built a wall
we're building a base over here so you
guys don't have to be scared yes well
yeah
oh boy it sounds like that's not
changing
i know to get to you i have to pause
this two of them oh jesus christ
don't bring it over here i'm sorry i
can't go anywhere else because there's
two of them
i am running towards you i'm going to
run away i'm going to run away it's fine
it's fine
oh i'm sorry i keep screaming chat it's
i promise it's not this is definitely
not for show i am genuinely terrified
okay oh he got me he got me oh no
it's a wolf spider that's bad news can
you lead them away from my backpack
i tried to lead them away from the base
and i died for it you know
are you surrounded by him or no um
alana is he near you uh yeah
standing over you okay all right hold on
let me know yeah that that seems like a
weird thing that after they down you
they just stand there so there's no way
for you i see you that bruce
oh boy he's bruce are you
i have an acronym yet he sure is
right [ __ ] there i want to help you
but
why did you make a noise why you might
just leave me alone
no oh god
i'm sorry lana i'm sorry it's five
it's fine just don't worry about it okay
all right alana's dead
and there she goes and there she goes
don't worry it's only like a 10 minute
walk back to your stuff right
and it's nighttime i think maybe it's
only like two feet away yeah
i can't see [ __ ] um
[Laughter]
oh god i'll get more glass yep i agree
oh yeah i should build a lean too up
there so we can make our spawn point oh
god i can't see a thing
what is this a sap oh we love zap he
loves to see it yes
okay um
oh yeah to lean to for for sleeping
yeah maybe i'll get there you know maybe
you'll get there
get to get to pete
i'm trying but i'm scared i'm shook what
is the setting you know how this game
has a setting to make it less scary what
does it
do oh yeah i don't know actually that's
a really good question
hmm here we go cool it like locks
together an acorn shovel
yeah i like that it shows you what other
people have discovered in terms of
crafting that's cool
yeah oh my god it's cloverly
here's my shovel
those grubs you guys have shovels those
grubs are incredibly useful
but they're really hard to find okay
the arachnophobia thing changes spiders
into orbs
i guess orbs
oh i'm here i made it i think yeah how
about you just get over your phobia
i've been super afraid of them like my
whole life you know
let me know if you uh it's a [ __ ] okay
i'm here
i have made shovel okay i need more i
need grass
maybe we'll make a lean tube we'll go to
sleep yeah
yeah yeah yeah did you end up getting a
backpack
i got my backpack you did so can i walk
out that way maybe
i mean this is probably at your own risk
maybe if we sleep you know will my
backpack despawn
make it a lean too real quick okay
should be fine
hope so i guess we'll find out oh where
you going
there bud right there there we go number
one crafty boy
that's me set respawn point boom set
that respawn point don't forget that
set respawn point okay three out of four
ready for nappy time
okay let's do it pete's gonna build
i hope my backpack's still there it
is let's see if it's a spider-free zone
i was hoping this would be exactly like
the seven days to die stream we're all
just digging holes the whole time
yeah yeah i missed that let's go back to
that i can make a storage chest i make a
storage chest crap
yes the storage system is incredibly
useful oh pete's so fragile careful
sorry sorry sorry i was killing that nat
oh okay
that maybe is a spider leg but i'm not
sure um
does it have a big fighter attached to
it i've made a chest see that looks like
it's probably going to be a
boom right chat right that
you know all right we got a chest
everybody
um can these acorns fall from the tree
and kill us because they are
large not that i've seen though um okay
so again if you see oh man there's those
those [ __ ]
grubs the grubs are the bane of my
existence they're like
really hard to find it is a spider cool
face your nemesis my [ __ ] backpack
you know
you giant [ __ ]
the scariest species of spider
oh my god is there any way i can be
helpful while we wait for dumb [ __ ]
spider [ __ ] to
go away here hold on i'll escort you
okay how's that going i'll i'll draw his
aggro
oh okay well he's uh right back
you'll see him see his legs
yeah you making a workbench sold on the
other roses there's a workbench right
here
what the [ __ ] was that you serious
judd john john oh gosh
don't worry it's on the other side is he
failing
come on over here come up there yeah
come on
just don't let me run
oh
jesus jacob did he not see me he did he
did but you're good
we need to finish the walls jacob is
bleeding
tickle tickle tickle oh my god oh my god
okay
okay okay yeah i got it i got it there
we go
now what uh we'll go go back to base
just go back just go straight back walls
don't work walls don't work it's just
[ __ ] crazy oh boy there's a
that was bad that was bad there where is
it yeah it's still there
still there what happened to that spot
bruce are you still there he's still
there i'm here
he's still there it'll be fine you're
right he is kind of stuck
i like that hey
[Laughter]
that was
don't worry about it head ah one shot oh
my god
[Laughter]
shoulders i can't believe that happened
that was the scariest thing ever oh [ __ ]
i made a hood but where'd it go like
yeah yeah we're good we're good just go
and then oh my [ __ ] god i'm sorry i
keep yelling i wasn't expecting this to
be a horror game but here we are
[ __ ] house you busted up this acorn
real quick
oh [ __ ] sorry this is just thank you for
trying to help me bruce i appreciate it
yeah no it's all right i uh it's coming
back it's coming back
john is coming back don't worry about it
i think that's the one that killed us
you guys
that's the one that killed us yeah it
killed bruce and i
where is it anyway this game is coming
down the middle so that's cool
isn't it because he's not gonna sleep
well
somebody's gotta help jacob build i need
more grass
more gross yeah oh there's my aunt club
um
what does grass look like that's
different to a plant fiber correct
it looks like grass that's like the big
blades of grass that chop down
oh okay okay okay i got you okay when i
i need more grass
it appears again it's the same one too
and it makes the worst sound ever when
it charges
also two of them dude go go around john
oh jesus
it keeps getting
but that i think that's a really great
idea because i am terrified of spiders
like if i was playing
up well by myself
[Music]
because of spider situation
that spider would just go away
oh god up here
did we maybe build our base at a bad
place
because we're relocating yeah we're
scouting right now
can we build a floor is that let me
check
base building there's roof performer i
don't think so
wait no yeah you can you can yes oh you
can yeah yeah
utilities um floor
maybe we just haven't researched it yet
or something spider's still there yeah
maybe
right now totally corner a little
platform up here did you accidentally
lock one of them
in the base ah john look you see that
you can see
if we had arrows or something we could
get it it's trapped oh i know watch this
what i missed i have permanent chills
and now my sphere is down there
oh wait no wrong way you press r you
press r to throw it
oh
oh my god it's destroying everything he
built empty yeah
oh god careful careful is it actually
damaging the base that's the thing
yeah it's busting up the walls oh wow
that's cool i can bust up
this game is glitched it
bit me from like inches away yeah that
dudes
guys our our base location is now
defunct
yeah the base location is going to help
me you got to save me jacob i can't even
get back
it won't get your backpack it won't kill
you it's literally
stuck inside our basement i have bad
news there's the second spider that's
right there
yeah but i think that one might also
maybe be so you're fine i think they may
be
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god this is not
embracing so many of them
i'm so brave john pete's so brave
i wouldn't want in either direction i
would like to die
all right jacob i can't get back to you
get our stuff and get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah
okay where are you guys going all right
i emptied the chest we're gonna go up
okay
up the branches so we're gonna build up
on the trees just
kill me i'm gonna i'm gonna head down
the hill to that research station and
research some stuff
oh why are there so many it's gonna kill
me again
are these wolf spiders like just don't
do they love the tree
are the tree their favorite thing okay i
think it's because we're near the um the
wall and i think that they actually hang
out at the wall
well they also live they live in that
thing great
i love that for us goody
i don't know how to get my backpack back
that's all i want it is it's just my
backpack
it's where i shall build
maybe i just give up on everything and
start over probably i am
go geez
jacob if you pick if you pick a place
for us to build then i can start making
stuff
i think john probably found a place i am
cowering in the research center because
there was a spider outside waiting for
me
yeah i decided to abandon my backpack
and um
just start over so i'm doing that spider
you guys all right here i'm i'm going to
teach you how to fight spiders
i'm going to teach you how to fight them
because
we block their attack there's a specific
yeah you can block their attack
it's not it's a lot easier with armor so
i'm trying to get a base going so that
we can build something
and uh and then i can and i can show you
that with armor but
it almost worked out other than the
except the spider was sat on top of our
workbench
[Laughter]
all right where's john john's up there
okay
yeah oh god the spider's still there no
thank you
no i mean who is this the other backbone
oh the second spider good grieving
yeah there are a lot of them it's just
not crazy none of it's a good idea
you're drowning gravy jacob this is
where they live this is where they live
[ __ ] yeah i'm not going back there look
where i
am are you safe
john you're in the wrong i mean like
there
there's no way
there's no way a spider's getting up
here you're right i don't know watch
this but i like it
bruce are you watching hold on look at
me rubbing i'm grubbing
hold on look at me bruce i'm grubbing
all right go ahead i don't
oh what wow nice toss
oh yeah glitch this ladybug's fighting
them
despite it
[Music]
ladybug please defend me ladybug oh my
gosh it [ __ ] jumped dude
ladybug fuzz okay
uh nat fuzz one of my backpacks has
natfos but
no no it is all right i think i ain't
got [ __ ]
i don't see any gnats from up here oh
oh that wall that you're talking about i
understand now
so so jacob where are you building yeah
it's fine i just
i just got to safety so i have yet to
find a new place to build
uh can you come in my direction i feel
like my direction is
i'm in the perfect place more
spider-free yeah except we can't make
floors
i mean we could we could just clear out
a spot if you want
what if we go to juice box why not juice
boxes yeah i'm pretty close to juice box
that's why yeah let's just do this
come here somewhere nice and flat yeah
okay yeah there's grass everywhere
like what if we just like hone up on the
juice box
you know because it also spawns food
yeah let's do that
uh it's it's one screw but not very long
so like it'll only do it in a few days
and then it'll go
well it'll be a good tint post for us
it's not it's not infinite that's what
i'm saying
um
okay i have give me some grass
uh how do i get you guys right away axe
do i need next yeah you need an axe oh
there's a spider heading for a juice box
there's a spider coming your way
that's it i'm gonna i'm gonna kill him
again oh my god
all right i'm with you bruce oh [ __ ] why
does he keep it oh no i'm not i'm
definitely not gonna kill him
i'd like one health but i'm with you
okay well blocking with the spirit
doesn't work at all so turn it off i
feel like i probably say oh i can't
oh god it keeps happening oh god
[ __ ] yep i've i already worked out today
i feel like i'm burning
so many calories with how we're like i
would love to have a heart rate monitor
on me right now
can somebody can somebody's distracted
oh i don't know bruce can i
is he on you oh my god this bandage
heals nothing of my health it takes a
while
it takes a while
run these spiders are bullies oh i'm
down i
[Laughter]
did it leave do we have spoiled baby
i'll try to come for you john oh i
didn't know
i got rid of all mine i might spoil that
i am no i do not i i
don't think oh oh yeah
is this what you think spiders feel like
uh when they're around humans though
do you think they're like oh he's back
he's hung from what
oh i could die
uh jacob can you rest me again yeah is
that spider still there
oh probably right next to me it's
prowling
all right i'm going to start hacking it
trees
okay congrats for you oh bruce i want to
get you
that spider's guarding you yeah he is
guarding me it's true
oh i guess where am i going to unload
these when the opportunities my leg
things go
uh a good place around here
i got you bruce
okay got it all right i have my club
i kind of like this this place was not a
bad spot to be honest with the juice box
or
where
okay i'll head over there it's really
not that bad
um we just gotta kill those spiders
that's all right now i am on
i don't know uh some sort of
machine okay i got one hidden and then i
died
um the machine seems safe but
i don't know like could we not build the
space inside of it
i'm doing really well i think you can
hey hey little [ __ ] punk
do you attack me that spider's still
coming for you guys
oh you want to build it on top of this
thing well i mean or inside
we left we left and that spider went
straight for us
immediately so we could i mean
where we are where alana and i are is
not bad either right i'm right i'm
pretty close i'm coming over pretty cute
i'm going your way oh this looks nice
yeah i like it
i don't know what it is
pete's ready
so i feel like even if we can't build on
our inside it which
the game maybe wants next to it yeah
there's some open space here i feel like
this is a good
oh that is spider head in your way oh
you can't spider head you're [ __ ] me
you got to be [ __ ] are you kidding me
don't draw them to us what is drawing
them
run the other way literally it's
literally just
going towards you there's only four of
us and one of it
does well they still can't kill it does
anybody have a spoiled meat or anything
can it get in here oh
this is i do not just oh i can't even
get up here
stupid spider oh
this is just oh my god this is actually
my worst nightmare it's a giant spider
i'm going inside here i'm going inside
yeah i fell in there no wait there's no
way they can get inside
i don't think it can do strat it's a new
strap [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm pretty sure uh okay so there's
another strat today
it's knocking my my grass everywhere if
you if you have rocks
you can we can [ __ ] [ __ ] if you have
rocks we can all throw rocks in it and
concuss it
and then it'll be stunned for a second
we can still have five rocks
i have five rocks does that make sense
my spear so here let's you want to throw
some rocks at it okay i got rocks ready
this is just like the lord of the rings
yeah that actually makes me feel a
little bit brave but thank you for
saying that
all right did we just make it back off
i don't really know why you're coming
back
you you should not be allowed to jump
that should be illegal
oh my god we've done so little damage to
it that's so funny
oh my god we have to st we have to stun
it
okay that's i think i think it's gone i
think it's going down
it's gone it might have some venom venom
by it for a second
all right oh my god water container
how about uh what if we tuck it back
here behind these like this big rock
or a little base sure yeah sure i'm just
gonna
i'll uh i've got a bunch of grass for
you jacob
okay can i go bring it back the spider
jonna will kill you
you may have all them pebblets oh
that was a pleasant sound oh is that
some grass what is this
we got some grass for you it's a water
container all right give me some grass
water thank you very much i'm gonna go
get some more water for you guys
and i'll tell you all right um i'm gonna
just keep um
uh mining for um i'm gonna cross so much
grass
right now oh yeah dude all right i just
made
a workbench sweet
okay i'm gonna make another lean too oh
[ __ ] more any more sprigs
can you make a chest so i can empty my
pockets yeah yeah
i'll make that first i'll make that
first
construct i'll put it right next to this
we've discovered this
what is the red there's something
blinking and it seems like my health is
like
going down a little bit did you get a
bit or something isn't it
no i haven't gotten hit once the whole
time playing this game
oh i need two sprigs okay something out
of here don't know what these are
clovers maybe we'll need a clover who
knows
let's find out can't wait yeah give me
them sprigs
just like the forest i'm pro deliverer
yeah okay lean too
okay what do you need jacob just give me
toss so i can de-stress
i'm still i feel like my heart rate is
very high give me
all that grass lean to build make that
your
spawn point oh yeah right next to the
chest
i would like to do that and one day i'll
go and get my [ __ ] backpacks
of which
uh small point
cool great does anyone have four
nat fuzzes i'm trying to get that nat
for a while huh
i do but i'm pretty far away what do you
need him for
make a bow to come back with the homies
i'm quick
if you want to come to where i am i'm
looking for i'm trying i'm hunting for
water currently
oh our lean twos and kind of i'm gonna
i'm gonna rebuild the guy who said he
hasn't been hit the whole time was lying
he's dying oh wait
are you you said you're building a lien
too yeah i'm gonna make another one
right now
all right okay bruce i'm gonna do we
need to set my up on point
and then come to you um i i i i made it
again
just because it wasn't a bad spot oh
okay let me breathe
so attach it let me know guys if you see
a if you see a bunch of water droplets
um i need to grab them with my canteen
okay
okay lean two's up it's right next to
the chest again
i like the little little jingle it gives
you when you set your spawn point
have you ever seen look at jake uh look
at john can you do that again
like go to the lean tee
just a little squat there yeah sometimes
it makes you literally lean backwards
um it like just straight up makes janky
[ __ ] happen
it was difficult for me you're not far
away you're you're like i'm not here
there you go john i'll drop him for you
clearing out the grass i am very calm
of course thank you very much and now to
to build
arrows for that bow there are thistle
plants
those plants are relatively hard to find
but i know there's one out by the lake
um by the lab you know
uh-huh do you mean in spite of fuckville
oh god usa
pause on that dude
okay wood stems where do wood stems come
from
okay well i got you ma grass all right
yeah i probably just have to find some
kind of like wood
like plants uh maybe wood oh hey ladybug
this is my phone is this doing anything
no yeah i probably have to find some
like stick plants to knock down
yeah hello ladybug what are you doing
here with your big bulging eye hello
we're cool with you you may stay
okay you want us to try to find wood
related items
yes i need wood stems so you probably
just need to find some kind of
does anybody have any spider silk i
heard a lot of something oh there's a
ladybug
i've seen some but i haven't actually i
didn't collect it i should have
does anybody have any spider silk at all
no sir
just one damn negative
okay all right because i want to make a
dude collector
bounce web almost
i got some arrows what are all these
bugs hey
this bug's going through our chest hey
oh yeah yeah
wait they do that yeah they destroy your
[ __ ]
wow what the hell this is a very
persistent survival game
um okay would for jacob is current
journey am very scared of outside world
but we'll go on quest forward for jacob
i think i see something that's made of
wood over here
i think what is that euphemism
pete's getting much more confident
[Laughter]
this is a weed i need a higher tier tool
damn it
oh
we like sap i'm scared to go in the
direction you're even in bruce because
there's nothing over here ladybug is
like humping our grass
dude and it's cooing
[Laughter]
dude you guys are gonna like this little
thing that i put down over here how easy
is it to kill a ladybug
no it's not easy they're tanks also we
made a rule
we're not you know we don't play like
that yeah jacob you son of a [ __ ]
pete's bloodthirsty
a roasting spit
wood stems i think you get from
dandelions if you look up i think
what's wrong buddy are you okay
some uh some strange a.i hey hey that's
our wall you stupid ladybugs
it's like it's her eyes are right i'm
going on an adventure trying to
attack something i think
this ladybug is all pissed off okay
chilled out what happened to you
oh you know what i think it saw this
aphid over here
oh you're right it did that is what it's
after oh
love aphids i'm very curious how they've
from a game design perspective made the
reflections on the ladybugs work
i know isn't that cool i'm wondering if
it's an accurate reflection because
usually reflections are fake
usually yeah just water collection yeah
that's a lot of info
to do a real reflection i don't know it
could
be but that's very complicated
i don't want to build more until i can
make a door
it is they've like lay it so that there
is a layer of
no yeah i think there's there are like
there's like one
there's one bit that won't but one bit
that will like you can i just saw your
reflection move on its back john
so i think that like there is yeah i can
see you i don't reflect
myself wait i see yours you'll see mine
if i move around right nope all right i
made a smile well maybe it's because i
have my settings on ultra a smoothie
station
i can see you officially
in mine yeah that's very cool but i
imagine
it's probably not the only way to sleep
yet i don't know whatever that's i'm
going on an adventure
never sleeping again super cool uh
i don't think so yet yeah we still we
have like a uh in-game hour left
yeah what else can i make here
what could i crawl does anybody have any
quartzite
um i might have one i've got oh no i've
got four
uh i need does anybody else have any
quartzite besides jacob
i put some in a chest oh here i'll put
mine in the chest too
yeah put all that in the chest where
where is that chest it's right next to
the workbench over here
oh how much
get oh we got a bunch of quartzite
there's like uh 24.
leave it in there because i need it for
our dude collector
i need more acorn shells there we go
i'll just take those
can we cook mushrooms i don't know
that's a really good question actually
um i can't hear you guys talking
oh like our characters yeah
i'm going down a hole it's very dark
and there's there's webs get those get
the spider silk
oh should i okay i can do that i can try
to do that
someone's trying to take our stuff again
help me with this thing
where's my spear oh i don't have a spear
all right take a [ __ ]
i really need to crop something yeah
shake his goodies
i'm very thirsty an axe torch would be
cool okay let's do more of this oh now
we can
now we can sleep yeah the light okay
really dramatically changed oh i need
some dragon
we're awesome where'd the lean to go oh
where did it go uh
oh [ __ ] is it did it get blowed up oh
maybe it did somebody broke it
um driving my torch how do i get those
my torch is gone no that doesn't work
that's what i'm trying to make right now
but i can't figure out
quite housy um am i just gonna [ __ ] with
my brother i need one plant fiber
uh i'm coming back with a butt load of
spider silk
i thought you were gonna say with
spiders and i was like john no
please please oh yeah they blew up
arlene too
look at you you [ __ ] nude
all right thank you let's do it
all right making another lean too does
that mean that we would have lost our
spawn point too
yeah probably that that leaning tube
i take sleep for the night i'm going to
sleep
i'm back uh bobby it's
a little bit like minecraft it's in the
same genre it's a survival
[Music]
i can't roast a mushroom i don't know
that's a really good question actually
i didn't seem like i could interact with
it more i assume that you could just eat
the mushrooms without having to
you can but i i don't know if you can
cook them
okay i need to find plant fibers
smoothie question mark yeah making
smoothies
sort of um
i don't feel like i need i need dry
grass chunks
those are really yeah that's the yellow
the yellow we got that water collector
slurp out of there that water
kind of sucks dead yellow grass
it gave me no water okay usually
it needs we need uh we need a dude
collector and i
i'm working on that but um a jew
collector
i need uh john do you think so you said
you have spider silk right
i think i can craft i do i hate spider
silk
i just need one john can you hand it to
me i'm right next to you
oh you're watching me
i saw a bug a mug oh
i'm trying to make a torch
hold on cruise get the nat okay it's
just a map
justin that's the first night i've ever
seen uh how do you make a better
i don't know if i'd say it's better than
force
i need to make a better axe so i can get
wood
okay i need weeds john do you want to
come on
now come on uh
to find some weed stems no i'm good damn
it's cool
great i need some help so we can make
this dude collector we
don't have to worry about water as much
yep oh yeah i should probably research
more stuff too huh
yeah i mean it's that's right here we we
are are you at it okay yeah damn it i
need water still
oh [ __ ] i do too i didn't even realize
how badly i needed water
uh where is my where's my petals i said
necesito agua
you're not wrong
oh i'm getting a little thirsty too it
turns out
i mean my food meter is flashing but
isn't it literally going to be flashing
the whole time
well i mean you just need food it looks
like but i mean it's full
my food meter is full are you sure
well that's yup you sure it's not empty
the opposite of full
i drank a smoothie and it filled up
there you go
are you two full did you find it happen
maybe
what what is it what what's wrong
john no i look at me look where i'm
going
okay sure yeah is he bragging
i don't know he made me nervous
it wasn't a scared oh it was uh there is
there is there is a map
i didn't even know yeah there is
okay yeah what do they look like
bruce i see a spider
like they look like standard weeds would
in a uh in a garden
oh hello ants leave me bee
no oh what what what
everything okay what who screamed oh
yeah yeah
oh no his brain
[ __ ] i fell on i sprained my ankle
oh no but i'm gonna
are these weeds right here these red
plants maybe just chop them down
or if you can it doesn't look like a
weed
i need those mites for my arrows sorry
yeah
yeah i forgot about it again i'm not
going to that wall
uh these might be weeds what it's a bomb
or deer broodle
okay that's all right is this a weed
it's trying to shoot it's goo with me no
that looks like a foot
there's a spider oh that's the spider
sounds fine
maybe it's not fine it says thread
engaged jacob i'm running
vaguely in your direction
why am i so hungry i prefer home base
home is good
spiderling where's the research station
i never found it nice
oh wait i have a map
i'm so hungry champion yeah it's not
easy
to take care of those at the stage we're
at i guess it'll get easier later in the
game but
there we go there is a field station
hey you watch it you stupid might
yeah you tell them you tell them boss
all right do you guys have these
objectives for completing markers at
beacon in spain
i think a pink or a purple
flower on the top of it looks it looks
like a thistle plant it looks like a
weed
oh actually see the research station
thank goodness
still really trying to find a weed
i'm trying to get home i got too too
panicked
yeah go home for a nap
this is going to be scary i can't
analyze any of this stuff oh i got a
bunch of spoiled meat i should get rid
of this
you should spiders
oh gosh i'm lost
bruce what are you in the direction of i
am by the
uh tree because oh that's why i [ __ ]
up i shouldn't have followed you i can't
even okay jacob you're
over here i'm new i'm over here by the
research station okay i'm using the
acorns for food because you need a lot
of food
i'm just i need do i need a cheer cute
ass craft
i think it's two two acts got this wood
stems but
i assume we need to research to be able
to make them
a couple of ants here ant parts um
don't kill these two ants john they're
trying to stay hey hey this is our place
i could help
damn you loot so fast jacob
huh oh yeah pete's greedy
classic i can't like there's not much
more i can make without
good what was that
more ants
i know i am in desperate need of water
well let's go find some dew drops
behind you yeah ants
killed some mushrooms up here yummy what
can i craft
now uh i already have a spear i think i
need water too
that dandelions for wood stem oh there's
the dandelions i see a bunch
no yes i'll find me a dandelion
[Music]
yes yes yeah cut dandelions they may
have those may have weed
here's one oh
oh perfect oh okay nope it's fine what
what what's happening
did it have weed sticks jacob um
i just chopped it down let's see
congrats oh yeah i think this is wood
stems
oh weed stems yeah cool
dandelions that's the answer
for what um that's what we need for a
bunch of stuff
nice so now i just need
three grass planks
hmm where's all that grass oh yeah she's
sort of like to the right of the base i
guess so behind it maybe there we go
in the in the grasshole this is pretty
sweet actually
meal prep
the smoothie station seems awesome
mushroom garden seems more awesome get
out of here ants
ice okay caps it's all right
[ __ ] [ __ ] jump out here these look
delicious
oh the things in that little ice caps
box yeah yeah those look really yummy
cool i don't think i got me a new outfit
cool guys do i look fancy let me see
whoa cool very nice you can live it off
the land
yeah you can get in there cause i can
farm it with a level two hammer
you can farm mint oh i open the cap
okay what else do i want do you have
level two
no uh john do you want a torch i don't
need stem
i only have one everything i know me too
um
where's that research station
oh there's one what you already have
that's right door it's fine oh
um
it should yeah okay i think this is
jacob's game right
yeah uh oh yeah i guess yeah that's the
thing i would like to return to it
but also i'm sleepy yeah
so you know i hear ya that's what's up
um all right will see you guys later
all righty have a good one alana yeah
this is fun we gotta play this again
yeah i'm down all my belongings have
been in
uh thank you for watching everyone i
feel like i crafted all the like tools
that i could craft before having to
level up and uh
go and be more spiders which was
terrifying
so um you know there's that but i'm into
this game
very buggy for sure like had trouble
even getting into it but it's pretty and
i love survival games in general i
always have a fun time with them i never
stick with any of them for super long
so i don't know that i would play this
for a really long time but um it's
really cute
and unique and yeah i appreciate what
they did
uh i will see you guys next time
bye